charges are pending this morning for a
Southwest Airlines pilot after TSA
agents say they found a gun in his
carry-on bag at st. Louis Airport TSA
screeners nationwide are finding more
firearms than ever and on Capitol Hill
the agency faces criticism for its poor
performance in undercover tests Kris Van
Cleave is at Reagan National Airport
just outside of Washington Chris good
morning good morning TSA officers are
finding guns at checkpoints across the
country at a rate of nearly 12 a day and
the most common explanation when it
happens passengers will say they simply
forgot the gun was in that bag TSA
screeners at st. Louis's Lambert
International Airport spotted this
loaded 9-millimeter Smith & Wesson in a
carry-on of a Southwest Airlines first
officer who had planned to board a
flight to Las Vegas the 51 year old
pilot was arrested and the airport says
charges are pending
the TSA s Instagram is full of pictures
of guns found at checkpoints so far this
year officers have stopped more than
3,700 from getting through that's up ten
percent from all of last year and the
numbers have been rising for a decade
this latest incident comes as the TSA is
facing heavy criticism for missing at
least 70 percent of prohibited items
brought through checkpoints during
undercover tests earlier this year
Florida Senator Bill Nelson you've been
briefed on this report how concerning is
this I mean this is hair on fire the
testing is done every two years in 2015
the TSA failed 95% of the time what do
you think that says about the level of
security at those checkpoints at
airports across the country I'm just
amazed
that a terrorist has not come through a
checkpoint and done some very bad things
on an airplane Department of Homeland
Security Inspector General John Roth
appeared before the House Oversight
Committee yesterday we found
deficiencies in the equipment we found
deficiencies in the personnel and we
found deficiencies in the process by
which they interacted with the equipment
the Inspector General says the TSA is
showing some signs of improvement and
the agency is working to address eight
classified recommendations made from
this testing those likely include
improvements to equipment as well as
training we know in 2015 the TSA began
retraining more than 40,000 screeners
but many of the officers who didn't do
well in this testing said they were yet
to receive that new training Gail thank
you very much Chris Van Cleve